I want to remind you of one of the
questions we looked at before which
requires this skill but we didn't know
how to solve it back then because will
focus on indices this is the question
does anyone remember does it not
remember looking at it mrs. Lee's showed
it to you and you're kind of like what
do I do with that you're like I know the
indices stuff I know how to do that know
how to handle the indices but this is
some breed of equation I don't really
know how to work with right so we're
going to call on this memory what we've
revised here to deal with this guy okay
so someone would give us not the answer
but a first step what do I can okay so
you can see there's lots of two's here
like there's a this two twos hidden here
there's one here and there's an eight
hidden here so there's three of them in
there right so I could pull out two from
the whole thing before I do that though
it's kind of a bit tricky to see like
for example this guy here don't write
this down because it's wrong this guy
here right if I pull too out of it like
this why is this wrong because it is why
can't I just pull two out what do you
think yeah okay so what's really going
on is this right that's actually what
this is right so you have to be it's
quite dicey factoring out things from
indices and all that you've got to be
quite careful with them so I wanted to
think back to when we were solving these
equations with indices what did we do
what was a tool that we often did very
the first thing in order to make the
factorization a bit easier remember when
you got all these numbers with different
bases it's awkward right what do we do
that could help us instead of writing
them in different bases we could yeah we
could get consistent basis and this
would make it much easier to deal with
right and we kind of already see that
here
so I'm gonna write for and I suggest you
write 4 as well as 2 squared ok with
that
I'm getting the same bases I have over
here that's 4 and that's been raised to
the power of X so far so good
now over here I also have this two to
the power X they don't go to plus one
what does the plus one mean in that
index yeah multiplied by two one more
time if there was like an a three here
it'd be multiplied it by two three more
times or however many that number is
okay
so I'm going to use that fact and write
this with the same base right even
that's already got to there you told me
that that plus one means x to a single
time right so are you okay with this and
this being the same idea if you like you
can see this as two to the power of one
here and what do you do when you
multiply two numbers with the same base
what happens to their indices you add
them right now mrs. Lee's mentioned this
in one of our earliest lessons last week
we're used to going from this to this
right you see this you're like oh I know
my index laws and you put them together
but you're going to have to become just
as comfortable going in the reverse
direction and that's what we've just
done okay we don't actually need that's
a bit unnecessary and then I'm just
going to leave this guy hanging at the
end you'll see why in a minute
why didn't I put that in two cubed just
hold on now is this time to look a
little more familiar
I started off talking today we started
talking today I think about quadratic
equations and this doesn't look very
quadratic there's nothing squared in it
but there is now do you see this you see
that first term it's got a squared in it
I can make it a little more obvious by
taking these two guys and what does it
mean when you hit raise the power to a
power what are you gonna do with those
powers I'm gonna multiply them right so
this is actually 2 to the 2x 2 to the 2x
now I could write that but it's actually
gonna be more useful to me just to swap
those two powers around because in
multiplication 3 times 2 is the same as
2 times 3 right so 2 times X is the same
as x times 2 so I can switch that order
how I like why is this form I'm gonna
finish writing the equation now why is
this form more useful to me hmm
it's still a bit tricky to see yeah do
you see it very good the thing I have in
the brackets let me just highlight it
for you right and maybe you want to do
the same if you
having the brackets here and here is the
same it's consistent so this is just
like the quadratic equations we dealt
with just now except there's just a
weird thing here but no big deal
everything else is the same so to make
it clearer to you that everything else
is the same
I'm gonna do something which sounds a
bit fancy but really it's just to make
it easier for my brain I'm going to
introduce a substitution and a new
letter the conventional one that we use
is the letter u I don't really know why
but it works fine I'm gonna introduce
this new letter and I'm gonna write it
everywhere that I saw through the power
of X so this is a substitution I'm
introducing okay
so instead of this line everywhere I see
2 to the X I'll replace it with a you
okay so what will I get u squared that's
the very first term are you ok with that
2 to the x squared I'm gonna write u
squared instead it's a bit easier for my
brain to handle takeaway what comes next
oh my god here this is to lots of you
write to you very good
and then that minus a is just hanging
out there and we've just transformed
this problem which looked super awkward
and weird into a problem we're really
familiar with right that X that u T I
could call it anything I like right I
could have made it
Zacky squared minus 2 Z minus a it just
will take a longer to write right and
exactly we'll be happy about it
nonetheless I can still solve this right
can we factorize we're gonna do it just
like we did here we're gonna have to
think of two numbers and they add up to
they out of - watch carefully we
carefully look sorry - fun yeah that
minus sign comes to arrive right so I
want that pair of numbers they add two
negative two and I want that same pair
of numbers to multiply to negative eight
to hurt forget the negative it's a big
deal right in fact it completely changes
that answer as you'll see in a second
can you think of the pair of numbers
adds to negative two multiply the
negative eight yeah - and - for two -
what do you do you agree with that do
they work out what do you think he's a
native okay now we've got some
contenders here okay
which one is it because this is a thing
that's easy to confuse for example if we
just come back to this one which we were
all pretty comfortable with right you
think of the numbers two and three and
you put them into here but then your
answers end up being the exact opposite
of that so - signs are a really easy way
to like hold on which which way am I
going here let's just check this shall
we if I add these two together here
negative four plus two is the final
answer negative or positive the Finance
will be negative that's the one I wanted
right if I gave this ago the final
answer will be positive and another of
these are we we want the negative one
yeah so I'm going to exclude that one
and give this one ago and this is an
important thing to do you will come up
with solutions all the time you're like
does this work or not and your ability
to check that not necessarily the
ability to get the first one right
straight away there bidded to check and
make sure you are getting the right one
that's really important